[Musique]
un lien d'amour face à la maladie Myriam
angelber 57 ans via ecuvilly dans les
Yvelines en 2019 lors d'une réunion de
famille ses proches s'aperçoivent de ses
pertes de mémoire après analyse le
diagnostic tombe elle est atteinte
d'Alzheimer précoce un moment douloureux
amplifié par le manque d'empathie de
certains médecins j'ai refusé et j'ai
dit j'ai dit non et puis j'ai dit de
toute façon
je suis un peu une battante quand même
et j'ai dit de toute façon je
m'arrêterai jamais c'est une prise au
moins moi je le vois comme tel alors
bien sûr on revient vous sortir etc mais
moi je peux plus prendre ma voiture et
partir et puis faire ce que je vais
faire
donc pour moi je suis en prison dans ma
maison un frein dans la poursuite de ces
projets avant sa maladie Myriam et me
faire des randonnées seules sur
plusieurs kilomètres sa perte
d'orientation du haut trouble cognitif
l'empêche de vivre sa passion en toute
autonomie je peux plus bouger je suis
dépendante tout le temps donc c'est
lourd
et puis après ben qu'est-ce qu'on fait
quand je me retrouve seule je touche
j'ai le côté tactile qui prend le dessus
comme quelqu'un qui est aveugle alors
qu'on ne l'est pas mais il y a des sens
qui sont effectivement
qui sont abîmées je pense c'est pas
abîmé j'appellerai ça comme endormi
suite à l'annonce de sa pathologie cette
ancienne ingénieur commercial dans une
société informatique a dû renoncer à son
poste une épreuve pour cette femme
active j'ai beaucoup travaillé puis un
moment il y a eu des petits problèmes
mais c'est je voulais pas en fait
peut-être les entendre je voulais pas
aller voir parce que pour moi j'adore
enfin j'adore ce job course cuisine ou
sortie une auxiliaire de vie accompagne
Myriam plusieurs fois par semaine dans
les actes de la vie quotidienne une
épaule précieuse pour son mari Hervé
malgré ses difficultés accumulées son
métier de banquier avec son rôle des
dents c'est un peu le jour sans fin
parce que tous les jours on recommence
les mêmes choses
les mêmes rituels il faut il faut aider
à l'habillement il faut moi tous les
jours je suis obligé de m'occuper de
tous les à côté les faire à manger faire
les lessives
faire faire le ménage grâce à
l'association France Alzheimer Myriam
participe désormais à des groupes de
paroles entre managers un moyen pour ce
couple de libérer la parole pour mieux
vivre la maladie